me escuchas con frecuencia utilizar la
palabra abstracto y por esta razón
decidí hacer una definición o más bien
dar la intuición de qué es esto de lo
abstracto y abstracto puede ser un
adjetivo como decir una idea abstracta
también puedes tener arte abstracto o
abstracto también puede ser un verbo
como abstraer ideas abstraer algo y
también puede ser utilizado como un
pronombre por ejemplo me viene a la
mente en el ambiente científico los
textos que escriben los científicos
tienen un resumen que suele llamarse
abstracto pero independientemente del
contexto en el que escuchemos esta
palabra abstracto nos referimos a esta
noción de lo esencial que tiene un
objeto del mundo real no importa que lo
usemos cómo pronombre como verbo como
adjetivo así que por aquí tenemos
nuestro mundo real sigue aquí está el
mundo real y por este lado tenemos las
ideas
y los conceptos la idea general detrás
de lo abstracto es tomar ese objeto
fuera del mundo real y llevarlo hacia el
plano de las ideas y los conceptos y
probablemente para mí una de las formas
de hacer más tangible esto del abstracto
y pero estoy diciendo una contradicción
cómo hacer algo tangible de lo abstracto
me gusta pensar en las figuras
geométricas por ejemplo si yo te dijera
muéstrame un cubo pues podrías pensar en
esta nave extraterrestre borg o tal vez
te refieras a un par de dados si a un
par de dados déjame dibujarlos aquí si
estamos buscando cubos podemos pensar en
dados y que se ven más o menos como esto
también podrías pensar en el cubo de
rubik también es probable que en tu casa
tengas una caja que es un cubo
pero en tu mente tienes ya una idea de
lo que es un cubo tú sabes lo que es un
cubo cuando beso 1 pero la idea general
es como destilar el concepto de que es
un cubo todas estas cosas son muy
distintas
este que está aquí pues es un objeto de
plástico que puedo poner en mi mano este
que está acá este pez ido pensamos tiene
las puntas un poco achatadas está de acá
pues es una gran nave extraterrestre
board claro es una cosa ficticia pero
ahí está pero todos ellos tienen un
carácter de cubo de los fundamentos de
la geometría y si tenemos una definición
en geometría de qué es un cubo y es un
objeto como este que está aquí en el que
cada uno de sus lados tiene la misma
longitud si este lado fuera uno pues
éste también será uno y el otro uno
aunque no tiene que ser un número
cualquiera que sea la longitud de esta
dimensión será la longitud de esta otra
dimensión igual que la longitud de esta
otra dimensión
bueno no voy a intentar dar aquí la
definición exactamente geométrica de qué
es un cubo pero tenemos una idea de lo
que es un cubo y en el mundo real no hay
nada que sea exactamente un cubo o sea
así yo tomar este objeto y lo midiera
con cuidado en tal vez no serían
exactamente igual dos lados pero en
nuestra idea abstracta de que es un cubo
este lado es exactamente igual a este
igual a este ya este también a
cualquiera de ellos así que podemos
decir que a partir de los objetos del
mundo real a bueno aunque en este caso
sean futuristas nos vamos a la idea a la
idea general que está detrás de esto y
también es probable que hayas escuchado
la palabra abstracto en el ambiente del
arte arte abstracto y aquí tenemos un
ejemplo y también si nos remitimos al
diccionario vas a encontrar muchas
definiciones pero todas se refieren a lo
mismo una de estas definiciones puede
decir el arte abstracto no trata de
reflejar la realidad
a diferencia del arte renacentista
donde se retrataba la realidad con mucha
detalle muchas veces el arte abstracto
ni siquiera trata de representar algo
que corresponde en la realidad a veces
es una expresión digamos cruda de la
realidad o simplemente una expresión de
colores y texturas este que tenemos aquí
es de jackson bola que espero estar
pronunciando bien los nombres y este
ejemplo lo tomé del historiador de arte
aaron stevens en este ejemplo jackson
por la que no estará tratando ni un
perro ni un caballo en ningún objeto
conocido por nosotros y ni siquiera
sabemos si esto corresponde a la
realidad y el concepto abstracción en no
nada más se refiere a los objetos
geométricos o al arte está inmerso en
nuestra vida diaria simplemente al
utilizar palabras o símbolos para
referirnos a algo estamos haciendo
referencia de una manera abstracta a
esos objetos de nuestra vida diaria por
ejemplo
utilizó la palabra perro pero observemos
es simplemente un conjunto de símbolos
que nos remiten a una figura como esta
que es un animalito que tiene cuatro
patas y tiene unas orejas suavecitas y
que nos gusta acariciar y también
decimos que es el mejor amigo del hombre
pero en el mundo real hay hasta grandes
diferencias entre los mismos perros es
una variedad de animales no es lo mismo
un gran danés que por ejemplo un fútbol
pequeñín pero reconocemos la esencia la
esencia de lo que hace este concepto y
podemos abstraer lo que es un perro y
también utilizamos estos símbolos para
representar el concepto de un perro pero
ahora quiero pensar en un número por
ejemplo si escribo el número 5 pues es
algo tan familiar a nosotros
aparentemente es un objeto concreto y
simplemente es una cantidad que yo
podría representar de diversas maneras
como
o como un 5 en romano o también puedo
representarlo de esta manera y en todos
los casos
todos estos símbolos y representaciones
se refieren a una cantidad de cinco
cosas y por ejemplo si yo le pregunto a
alguien muestran un cinco pues es
probable que seleccione esta
representación a este símbolo pero es
una idea sumamente abstracta con suerte
ya tenemos una idea de lo que significa
abstracto y ya falta de otra palabra
pues sólo puedo decir que es una idea
abstracta